another warrant issued for accused
sexual predator Nathan chasing horse
this is the latest in a series of cases
and investigations into the Dances with
Wolves actor eight news now investigator
Vanessa Murphy uncovering more about
allegations against him Vanessa the
latest against Nathan chasing horse
stemming from a case dating back to 2005
in Montana the allegations that he
sexually assaulted two girls ages 13 and
15. prosecutors declining to prosecute
back then citing a lack of evidence but
his arrest here in southern Nevada
prompted that case to be reopened
chasing horses accused of sexually
assaulting indigenous women and children
for two decades throughout the United
States and Canada and leading a cult
called The Circle A lot has unfolded
over the past two weeks so here's a
timeline January 31st he's arrested on
sexual assault and sex trafficking
charges in North Las Vegas February 2nd
Federal authorities in Canada issue a
warrant for sexual assault February 8th
Federal authorities here file a criminal
complaint for sex crimes against
children February 10th that warrant
issued in Fort Peck tribal court in
Montana
this evening chasing horse remains in
custody in downtown Las Vegas the FBI is
still actively investigating him in
multiple locations authorities in Canada
also say more charges are on the way